are you doing today sir good good so I
was just saying it before the camera
started rolling between this and the
lighthouse you're having an okay here
okay good I'm glad you think so
I think everyone thinks so um listen I
know that you you must be offered a lot
of stuff what was it about the script in
this project that said I have to do it
you know which is often the case it's
the director that's the first thing and
Edward approached me about doing this
and even before I read the script I was
kind of predisposed to it just because
it was clearly a passion project and I
liked Edward I knew him from before I
worked with him in a Wes Anderson movie
he's a smart guy
when he just told me in broad strokes
what the story was what the source was I
thought wow this is interesting and then
when I read the script I liked it very
much just because it had a lot of style
it was clearly one of those movies that
would have a film language to it it was
a film that would be partly Valentine
New York partly and was complex so there
were many pleasures and I liked the
writing I liked that these big speeches
that I had to do one of the things that
I commend Warner Brothers on is that
these movies are really hard to get made
nowadays it's true and oh sorry I know
just they're hard to get made because
they're they've got real content pretty
sure under present and there's not an
explosion every eight minutes yeah you
know there is but it's emotional yes
well you get to share you have a lot of
scenes with you get to share the screen
with Alec and not enough wood he's great
I mean most of my scenes are actually
with Edward sure but there's a few key
scenes with Alec yes and so how much fun
is it to play opposite him be I'm a I'm
a big fan of yours and Edward and Alec
and it's one of the compelling reasons
to see this movie okay the three of you
guys um well the I I didn't like Alec
and followed him for years I didn't
really know him but just when we met on
this
I you know liked him very much and was
eager to play those scenes I don't have
a lot of scenes with him but the
relationship we play brothers in it and
it's a very complicated almost
Shakespearean relationship and most of
that is played out a part it's not
played in scenes with him the scenes we
have together are quite they're quite
muted actually but anyway he's terrific
in the movie and I think his character
is is fascinating because he is sort of
the Darth Vader to my obi-wan Kenobi but
you listen to some of his speeches and
even though he's clearly a villain
there's a logic there it's not it's not
just the black hats and white hats
there's a complexity to these characters
and anytime with complexity usually
comes more curiosity from the audience
and they they have to go places that
they might not normally go it's not it's
not just the entertainment as
distraction it's entertainment as
engagement and as learning something
which you know it's it's a better route
to go or fight it why not get your cake
and eat it too a hundred percent